Well, can I say this? Can I say this, little guys?
I think one thing that's important to remember...
..is that...
You know, even though there's a lot of fun to Christmas...
...especially when it's snowy like this...
...so it's pretty outside. You got the Christmas tree, you got the Christmas cookies,...
...you got, you got presents.
You know, I think that...
...the most important thing is just to remember why we celebrate Christmas,...
...which is...
Do you know?
The birth of Baby Jesus...
...and the... and what he symbolizes...
...for people all around the world is...
...is the possibility of peace...
...and people treating each other with respect.
And so, I just hope that spirit of giving...
...that's so important to Christmas, I hope all of you guys remember that as well.
You know, it's not just about getting a gift but it's also doing something for other people.
So, being nice to your mom and dad and grandma and aunties and...
...showing respect to people.
That's really important too. That's part of the Christmas spirit, don't you think?
Do you agree with me?
You do?
Okay, do you have an interesting observation?
I know why we give gifts to other people.
Why is that?
'Cause the Three Wise Men gave gifts to Baby Jesus.
That's exactly right.